[Musique]
on s'intéresse aujourd'hui à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie full ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenu ou
midi de mon français un nouveau trancher
en faveur il y a quelques jours les
indépendantistes réclamer son report
après les échéances électorales
nationale contre les loyalistes
souhaiter la mort de mer pour en parler
avec nous Hamid Mokadem bonjour vous
êtes philosophe vous avez écrit
plusieurs ouvrages sur la philosophie
Canac vous résidez en Nouvelle-Calédonie
depuis une trentaine d'années elle les
indépendantistes du FLNKS part
historique et leur partenaire mettre en
avant la situation sanitaire le climat
n'est pas serein selon eux le territoire
un VTT épargné jusqu'en septembre mais
depuis la situation se dégrade et plus
de 270 morts du covit sur une population
de 270000 habitants près des deux tiers
à partenaire aux communautés océanienne
canin qui est Wally ciel
coutumier a décrété un bug dans non il
demande il soit respecté au-delà des
considérations politiques on va
évidemment aborder se pose déjà une
question d'ordre philosophique quel est
le rapport au temps et autant du deuil
et des Sociétés océanienne
je pense qu'il
faut bien contextualiser
parce que
la Martinique Guadeloupe
[Musique]
c'est rapport au temps qui est appelé
ici en anglais le Pacific time
et qu'ils ont un rapport structurel
historique s'il y a le temps qui n'est
pas exactement le même que le temps
imposé par l'administration de française
mais par le modèle économique français
je veux dire par là que si les
populations qu'on appelle les gens qui
sont là depuis 3000 ans déjà c'est
important c'est important ils ont une
histoire dans les autres populations ont
été ton histoire qu'on appelle la
transportation la cause et son peuple en
a à peine là depuis deux siècles qu'ils
ont un autre rapport à l'économie autant
et voire même à la vie est-ce que je
veux dire c'est que les populations
autochtones Canac quand il y a des
rituels ils sont partis des échanges
et qui nécessite effectivement une
mobilisation totale de toutes les
populations
il y a une il y a même une économie à
terme
d'échange ritualisé d'Auteuil
en ce moment qui
touche directement les populations Canac
et moins les population syrienne et qui
fait que
aussi bien les sénateurs
parti
pour mieux s'organiser parce que c'est
quand même question extrêmement
importante à tout à l'heure
parce que pour les indépendantistes il
est donc impossible de mener une
campagne et qui tape ce sont le retard
mais le royaliste lors que plus de 70 %
de la population calédonienne depuis 12
ans dispose désormais d'un schéma
vaccinal complet est-ce que la situation
sanitaire
s'améliore la situation
c'est quoi une campagne électorale il
s'agit la troisième référendum et que
les gens sont mobilisés par par le deuil
par des problèmes de pandémie Paris
problèmes autre être mentalement dans
une campagne
et même si effectivement la solution
depuis quelques jours
en octobre
je pense que
[Musique]
c'est
ils vont pas
comment créer de dissension ils vont pas
troubler l'organisation
politique premier magistrat de commune
il y a des mères et qui vont organiser
comme il se doit ils vont appeler
simplement leur population à ne pas
participer à ses potes
pourquoi pour démontrer aux yeux de
l'ONU s'il y aura les observateurs de
l'ONU pour démontrer aux yeux aussi des
observateurs du pays de fer de lance et
puis pour démontrer à la face du monde
que serait l'homme il est nul et non
avenu dans la mesure où dans les
populations intéressé la majeure partie
des populations intéressé qui sont
concernés directement par cette question
sur la souveraineté la dépendance ne
vont pas y participer donc la stratégie
c'est pas une stratégie de violence
pour sécuriser son sur un homme
plutôt tendance à
insécurisé
en 1988
en Nouvelle-Calédonie
de
aujourd'hui
de cette date du 12 décembre comme une
trahison
c'est logique le droit de voter à qui
veut pas
parce que il y a pas très longtemps et
des indigènes de la République
bien sûr que il y a une sonde de
déception et de trahison qui qui qui
peut être grave parce que la fragilité
du pays provient des déséquilibres
démographique et de volonté de
construire en communauté une même
communauté et tout d'un coup là les
enjeux comme il était politique
construite ensemble un petit peu biaisé
et mis de côté au départ de la
France
pour ne pas justement faire des
consignes d'intérêt entre les intérêts
des élections présidentielles est
l'intérêt propre à la Nouvelle-Calédonie
pourpre effectivement il y a une sorte
de sentiment de trahison paroles qui n'a
pas été respecté
dans les esprits les mentalités du côté
des indépendantistes et des royalistes
aussi quel constat est-ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui 30 ans après la
signature des accords de Matignon
c'est-à-dire que puis-je encore mise en
avant
entre le peuple kanak dans sa majorité
et puis les autres communautés une des
tentatives de
vouloir construire un peuple entre
guillemets
faut pas perdre de vue quand même que
[Musique]
je
te vois comme un espèce de morceaux de
sparadrap qu'on arrache une structure
dans laquelle
il y a pas de
encore mieux être accentué je prends un
exemple de rapport à la vie à la mort
quand on voit que parmi les 280
personnes qui sont décédés
pas très bien venu en ce moment
dans un instant juste après une très
courte pause à tout
[Musique]
et vous êtes de retour dans la grande
interview nous sommes en compagnie du
philosophe Hamid à Mokadem pour évoquer
la situation en Nouvelle-Calédonie a
quelques semaines de l'ultime
consultation sur l'indépendance du
territoire lors des deux dernier
référendum indépendance a été racheté
acheter avec
56,7 pourcents +
53,3 pourcents quel poids représente
aujourd'hui à 1000 Mokadem les
independantistes dans le paysage
politique en Nouvelle-Calédonie quel est
leur place dans la politique locale
la proposition
c'est-à-dire que le premier référendum
et des sondages et de manière très
arrogante effet sur une partie politique
[Musique]
pour répondre de manière précise à votre
question au contraire il y a une
progression que tout le monde peut
participer 80 % de
la population
de tourner la page après
est-ce qu'il y a aussi peut-être une
opposition dans la société entre
loyalistes
façon ils sont chez eux et un jour ou
l'autre il s'estime qui sont
indépendants
tant qu'il y aura
des
hommes
normal que c'est une question
extrêmement importante traite pas cette
question c'est la vie ce qu'ils tiennent
le discours de dire qu'ils sont là c'est
ce sont ceux qui sont dans la peau d'une
économie de compétitivité du prochain à
Laval
déjà envoyé il y a des choses qui sont
masqués
dans
la principale
la question de l'économie que vous venez
d'aborder quelle est en général le
rapport de la population calédonienne à
la France aux deux là aussi la question
politique si on peut faire la
distinction représente la France pour la
société calédonienne c'est une
excellente question
un peu plus de temps je vais essayer d'y
répondre parce que c'est une question
que les plus grands artistes et
écrivains
je pense pas non plus dans les
populations calédonienne sont profonds
16 ils ont une idée de la France qui est
un petit peu utopique parce que c'est
qu'elle est Dounia de souche
viens
je pense pas que la politique de
l'administration de Mâcon contribue à
faciliter un lien renouvelé entre la
France
et de la population
il y a une petite portion de dentiste
qui sont du côté d'une
partie des Kanaks
pour l'indépendance mais parmi les
populations ils ont essayé de construire
sur des matériels économique
construire une usine de transformation
de
construire une économie
préfiguration des institutions
politiques
de la
population
Auchan de l'ONU l'archipel fait partie
des territoires à décoloniser c'est cela
peut vous appeler vous aussi pour quelle
raison et qu'est-ce que cela remplit moi
je voudrais des comme isation matériel
et mental
on a pas eu le temps d'en parler c'est
difficile d'en parler
économique mais j'ajouterai et on en
parle rarement l'emmental des 2 côtés
qui est Descartes
dans le stress et
psychose qui sont
sur la date du 12 décembre date du
référendum en Nouvelle-Calédonie la date
a été choisir en jouant choisi en
présence des loyalistes et en et
pendentif la déclaration finale prévoyez
notamment après cette 3e de consultation
et qu'elle console résultat elle
prévoyait une période de transition pour
élaborer un nouveau statut
institutionnels dans le cadre de
l'indépendance ou bien dans celui du
maintien dans la République ça devrait
être ratifier par référendaire à
l'horizon 2 juin 2023 là aussi ça promet
encore pas mal de remous selon vos
quand même j'ai répondre à mes questions
précises quand il y a eu des discussions
à Paris il y a pas eu tous les
indépendantistes
libération nationale est composé de
plusieurs parties politiques
et à charge la dépendance il faut
préciser ça la deuxième chose qu'il faut
dire par rapport à votre question
c'est que là je ne sais pas comment va
se faire une discussion parce que les
exige une discussion bilatérale
c'est-à-dire avec l'État français et
l'État français vous débrouiller avec
les autres qui sont votre côté parce que
en fin de compte tu les parlementaires
les sénateurs sont partis politiques
c'est comme j'ai dit si c'est le oui
cette
histoire
et le troisième et dernier référendum
sur l'indépendance de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie se déroulera donc le
12 décembre prochain on suivra
évidemment ça avec attention sur rt
France merci beaucoup amine Mokadem
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation je
rappelle le titre de votre dernier
ouvrage vous dois étudier conte
philosophique de nouvelles Calédonie
merci à vous nous avoir suivi je vous
pouvez retrouver cet entretien sur notre
site internet RP france.tv à plus tard
[Musique]